welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of wonder
woman 1984 whether you love this movie
and its deeper theme of want versus need
or if you had
questions about monkey paw law or how
diana could fly now but not 30 years
after this i
got you covered it's a new year i love
having big superhero movies with
overlooked details to find and buried
layers of meaning to dig into
because even if your understanding of
wonder woman 84 was good
it can be better hey there's chocolate
on there the film opens back at the
mascara
young diana's america ninja warrior
style olympic obstacle course
the color tones of this opening act the
titles the costumes the whole arena
it's all warm and gold a palette that we
do not see
again until diana suits up in asteria's
golden eagle armor in the final act
showing us how she goes full circle in
finally understanding the lesson of her
youth
no true hero is born from lies
to the golden warrior stereo she did not
become a legend out of haste
she did it through true acts of bravery
that golden hysteria is diana's true
ideal
and we will never get those kinds of
goals by taking shortcuts
shortcuts like random hillside fun
slides
that only leads to unearned entitlement
and
an insatiable thirst for more that is
the thematic undercurrent as we jump
forward to the 1980s a setting chosen as
the height of unchecked western
materialism the era when greed
was good on tv screens is pedro pascal
as
maxwell lord a dc comics villain who
gains the power to influence people
by getting in their heads here a get
rich quick tv personality who you could
compare to donald trump in the 80s but
lord's catchphrases and moves it's all
way closer to those of tom vu
whose infomercials are amazing have some
guts
make a decision come to my seminar in
diana's home the watch
she and steve trevor talked about on the
mascara in the first film rests on the
desk among her travels is a visit to
steve trevor's family ranch
she and etta candy from the first movie
can be seen liberating a world war ii
concentration camp
and that photo of elderly edda looks
like it is set
in the late 40s maybe early 50s based on
the clothes notice the new york skyline
behind them
shows no world trade her towers so it
was definitely pre-1966 when
construction began on those notice how
these photographs successively subtract
one member from her world war one group
until
it is just her with etta so that old
world war one photo that bruce
wayne later gives her which we saw taken
in the previous movie
was the one photo of them all together
the first of this successive set all of
this sets up diana's loneliness in this
movie she gazes upward overhead at
planes thinking of steve trevor director
patty jenkins said
this shot of diana looking up at the sky
in georgetown was the final thing they
shot for the movie which is why it has
such a nice parallelism with the edited
final shot of the film
when diana lets some kids christmas get
ruined now it wouldn't be the 80s
without
a mall a mall with a jewelry store that
deals with black market artifacts it was
a weird decade
the name kozlov jewelry could be a nod
to the dc villain
colonel kozlov diana tears out the
security cameras to maintain
some semblance of continuity with her
anonymity 30 years later despite not
really staying low-key in any other way
kristen wiig plays barbara minerva
a clumsy shy girl who transforms into a
confident feline villain not
unlike michelle pfeiffer as selena kyle
in batman returns they actually
foreshadow barbara's cheetah future with
her reaction to diana's animal print
shoes
right have a nice day but those are cool
i like those
animal print these early scenes also
frame barbara with that stuffed big cat
behind them
in this shot lunging forward from her
head toward diana
the macguffin of course is the dream
stone based on the dreamstone ore
materiopticon in the dc comics it was
used by dr destiny against the justice
league allowing the user to will their
dreams into reality though here it is
made of citrine
quartz with citrine representing
prosperity
and wealth often referred to as the
merchant stone or the money stone so if
you can see how it is used in this movie
that way diana reads its latin runes and
later determines it was made by the
deity if you were listening closely
dolos who is a trickster demigod protege
of hephaestus the greek god of the forge
the implication being that dolos the
liar could have used his master's forge
to
construct this token of faustian evil
the lab worker uses a stone to wish for
a coffee and hey it works but lord is
the little moment that comes right after
he burns his mouth a little price he
must pay for getting his wish
monkey paw style it's incidental small
wish small price
a happy accident that feels like just
random luck
fortune or fate had this movie held
itself to
this rule instead of you know whole
desert walls and
nukes manifesting out of thin air or
free will being subverted
things would have probably been a lot
easier to follow in this movie
as steve's watch twitches back to life
on the shelf
is a book about the history of gorillas
maybe a nod to the flash villain gorilla
grodd the history that i really hope
gets explored in the upcoming flash
movie
barbara's homeless friend leon is
reading waiting for
godot the samuel beckett play a little
war play
for how this scene is waiting for godot
to come and say barbara smoke show
barbara meets max lord who does his big
line
life is good but it can be better now he
opens his hand on it can be better but
when it cuts back to barbara
his finger is still pointed it's an
editing error but it is kind of
interesting how it reflects the whole
monkey pod trickery of his character
how his generous offers are really
deceitful demands of something more
valuable in return
of course lord is a fraud and he's
called out by his
investor simon stag which is another
name from dc comics head of stag
industries villain to the flash at the
gala steve
trevor returns in the body of a stranger
whom diana recognizes by the way he puts
his watch in her hand but watch
closely as the camera spins around them
jenkins said they pulled this off with
well-timed choreography and he can see
where the switch happens because for
just a moment christopher palaha
leaves the frame allowing chris pine to
step in but gal gadot
sells it by never redirecting her eye
line really well done here i also like
how this kind of matches the
twist reveal in the post credits scene
the back of head that we thought was
just diana was actually
a different person the predecessor whose
spirit diana has been invoking
linda carter now regarding the
problematic nature of diana and steve
using this body swapped non-consenting
stranger as a
doll i'll direct you to jenkins citing
this as the 80s movie trope scene
in tom hanks big which features a woman
sleeping with
a child in the body of a grown man but
you know kind of sweetly ends with an
awakening from that wishful dream that
kinda
erased what had transpired i mean i get
that but you can't really
expect the values of movies made 30
years ago to
still hold true in 2020 without the
whole forgiveness that nostalgia lends
those classics
really the issue is why does steve
require an existing body surrogate when
other wishes just kind of manifest out
of thin air when you don't explain this
logic
confusion will just spill into all kinds
of problematic nooks and crannies
the second act reverses the dynamic of
the first film this time steve is the
fish out of water trying on
awkwardly fitting clothes and checking
out the train of the time
diana's beige jacket vest and white
blouse here is a direct throwback to
linda carter's wardrobe in an episode of
the tv series
diana and steve steal a freaking jet and
steve
somehow knows how to pilot it from a
cockpit that would totally look like
extraterrestrial to a world war one
pilot but hey
that didn't stop will smith and
independence day maybe that's what those
fourth of july fireworks are all about
let's just assume that for the sake of
our sanity but this jet becomes wonder
woman's iconic
invisible jet when diana uses that old
cloak and spell that her father zeus
used to hide the mascara lord meets with
amir saeed bin
who gets his wish for his ancestral
lands to be returned to his beyond
dynasty biala is the fictional country
in dc comics connected with black adam
though
it's technically supposed to be located
in the middle east like north of either
saudi arabia or iran which
are two very different locations but
it's not supposed to be on the african
continent along the nile in cairo but
maybe that's something dc films are
changing for this upcoming black adam
movie with rock
diana and steve chase lord on this
desert road where
diana learns in exchange for steve's
return she has lost her invulnerability
this trope of d
powering the superhero in sequels is
similar to what we saw in superman 2 and
in spider-man 2. but then she pulls this
big move of getting dragged under the
truck feels like an odd to another with
cracking hero indiana jones when he was
dragged under that truck and raiders the
lost ark diana tells steve about the
origin of that golden eagle armor
the amazonian asteria her role model
from the opening sequence now the
flashback shows asteria using her wings
as shields against what
appear to be spartans maybe a nod to
zack snyder's work in 300.
lord meanwhile meets with the u.s
president played by stuart milligan
credited only as potus though he
definitely evokes 80s president ronald
reagan
and speaking of parallels to superman 2
this potus definitely looks and sounds a
lot like the president played by eg
marshall in that movie along with the
whole
setting of the white house in this
sequel lord's plan is to use the reagan
era sdi
strategic defense initiative aka the
star wars program that used orbital
satellites to try to shoot down icbms
but in this movie there is a secret
protocol to transmit to all tv screens
globally at the same time which for lord
would allow him to simultaneously grant
wishes and
receive their monkey paw prices in
return
because i guess he is touching them all
via
particles aka the uh wonka vision rules
of telecommunication
lord monkey paws some nukes to potus for
the power of the commander-in-chief
causing some war games level madness
so diana has to apply the lesson she
learned as a girl give
up what she wants the most and renounce
her wish gal gadot's heartbreak is
so real here and i love how patty
jenkins spins the
camera around her and steve
counterclockwise
reversing the magic that brought him
back
diana doesn't even give steve one last
look after she kisses and turns away and
neither do we he literally vanishes from
the movie behind that wall and we never
see his transformation back
kind of like a dream suddenly ending now
you are welcome to interpret this
however you want or even not bother with
interpretation but i see this sacrifice
as crucial
to diana's discovering her ability to
fly by letting go of what we think we
are entitled to things that we didn't
really earn
walking away from that is a choice that
empowers you and allows you to unlock
things inside you that you didn't even
know were there i mean this could be
emotional [ __ ] justification but
maybe her flight in this movie is just
something she needed to do as a rebound
from leaving steve
and when she just kind of leaps around
in batman v superman and justice league
it's because she don't need to fly
but hey i'd like this choice to have
diana run up pennsylvania avenue
the capital behind her which if you
think about it is the start of the
parade route that every u.s president
takes on inauguration day but her
destination is not the white house she
leaps over it soars high above in the
sky because her duty is to
the whole world and diana's lasso
connects with bolts of lightning now
in the new 52 era of dc comics diana
gained the ability to manipulate and
weaponize lightning thanks to her
bracelets which were made from the aegis
and this zeus connection is also the key
to her defeat of cheetah in the final
battle
she can electrocute barbara in the water
while herself staying immune from that
electricity diana confronts maxwell lord
in this telecom facility and notice
the music as we flash to lord's tragic
childhood
that music is hans zimmer in junkie xl's
track called
a beautiful lie from batman v superman
there a beautiful lie referred to the
way that we kind of learn
wrong lessons sometimes from our past
trauma now those memories can be vivid
and meaningful but
often they are lies that we're telling
ourselves but here
diana turns that meaning on its head you
can only have the truth
and the truth is enough
the truth is beautiful yeah so while the
lies we tell ourselves can be
intoxicating and effective
the truth that we open our eyes to can
be
even more beautiful so lord renounces
his wish to be that dreamstone himself
giving a
technical justification to undo the
wishes of all those touching him
via particles which i suppose is why not
everyone in the world has to verbally
renounce their individual wishes
barbara meanwhile reverts from apex
cheetah because
lord's renouncement restores her back to
her previous form though she stays with
power similar to diana because those
came from the dreamstone itself the
final scene
appears to have been shot during
reshoots as a new ending after the movie
was delayed to a christmas release
gal gadot's husband fieron varsano and
daughter alma
cameo on that merry-go-round while her
other daughter maya
joins patty jenkins real life son as the
kids throwing snowballs at diana
and after a few words with the handsome
doll she watches a star balloon fade
into the sky
symbolizing her willingness to let go of
sky-bound aspiration that held her back
before now again she is
able to fly she could have just flown up
there and grabbed that but i guess that
would reveal her secret that's not
really well kept so maybe
she just hates kids merry christmas
oh one last detail that i appreciated in
that post-credit scene revealing
linda carter as asteria past wearer of
that golden eagle armor
her turn notice how she turns with her
arm
out in a kind of flourish the subtlest
gesture by carter calling back
her iconic spin in the wonder woman
series now look
obviously my opinions were mixed on this
film but i'm not gonna
try to make you feel one way or another
about it i hope if you liked it this
breakdown gave you more things to
appreciate about it but if you didn't
like it that's fine too
i hope i was able to clear some things
up or at least acknowledge some of your
confusion as valid
and have a few laughs over the logical
gaps that even the best movies in the
genre tend to fall into
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram at eavos follow me rockstars
subscribe to rockstars on youtube for
analysis and coverage of all the big
stuff that you love
thank you for watching bye
[Music]
you